in this morning's eye on earth we're
gonna take you to a place in the world's
oceans where great white sharks they are
thriving again oh no sharks play a key
role in keeping our oceans healthy but
their numbers have plunged by more than
70% in some places that actually is not
a good thing this great white is still
considered vulnerable but it's making a
comeback thanks to stronger
environmental protections Jonathan
Vigliotti shows us one of those
protected areas where the population
appears to be soaring good morning there
are only a handful of places in the
world where you are guaranteed to see
large numbers of great white sharks
mexico's isla Guadalupe is one of them
but the people who will be diving in
these shark cages didn't travel here 18
hours by boat just to see them they want
to help protect them this tiny speck of
rugged land is the definition of the
word remote and because it attracts
diving bugs like this one it's also a
beacon of hope marine conservation we
are in one of the most pristine
incredible hotspots for great white
sharks anywhere on the planet Andy
Casagrande is an Emmy winning filmmaker
famous for his work on Discovery
Channel's Shark Week but on this boat
he's the leader of an expedition to a
marine wildlife reserve protected by the
Mexican government there's everything in
the world that one could ever want to
eat here dolphins seals turtles tuna
cage divers just kidding
cage divers aren't in their food chain
but we are their visitors guests on
these trips paid thousands of dollars
for this experience generations of great
white sharks have been feeding around
this island for millions of years which
makes this an underwater Jurassic Park
at this cage one of the best ways to see
it all it allows humans to see sharks up
close and personal with their own eyes
the nice thing here is you get to really
get insight on some of their behaviors
how they interact their hierarchy
amongst the size groups and also just
how they interact with their prey the
visibility allows you to see some
amazing things that you would never see
anywhere else
those awesome right but the thrill is
only the beginning
while divers marvel at the oceans apex
predators casa grande is gathering field
data to share with scientists you call
yourself a Senate scientist what does
that mean cinema sciences this idea came
up with its the utilization of
cinematography cutting-edge technology
to help illustrate and perpetuate
science and conservation it basically
makes science palatable for the masses
marine conservation is Michael shoal
says that's the best weapon he has in
the battle against what he feels is an
unfair cultural stereotype obviously
that's the shark that pops in
everybody's head the moment you
mentioned the name shark the shark from
Jaws sharks are not the monster that
they'd be made out to be
it's probably one of the smallest
mortality causes for human beings days
crewmembers use bait to lure sharks
closer to the cages some people who are
critical of cage diving
they say that it's not natural for
sharks to be around humans the way that
they are with cages what do you say to
that eco-tourism does often catch flack
from skeptics that'll say well you're
throwing bait to these animals these are
wild animal you shouldn't be feeding
them the reality is if these eco-tourist
boats weren't out here the people that
would be feeding them would be poachers
and fishermen that would be harvesting
these white sharks it's also a way
that's garnered this area of protection
there's big money in ecotourism
the sharks are more valuable alive than
dead
100% and that value those way beyond the
money these people pay to go
face-to-face with great whites they do
change people's minds because you see
this beauty you see this gracefulness
getting people to see the sharks for
what they are basically is is a huge
education and obviously those people go
back and show that to their friends kind
of a snowball effect and changes other
people's minds and conservation word of
mouth is vital yes in that context the
most vital guest on board
might have been Florida elementary
school teacher Lauren says room
this was like the ultimate opportunity
to bring science in the real world to my
students
Andy inspired you to come out here and
now you're gonna take this home to your
kids I'm pretty sure you got the coolest
teacher in the world what do we know
about this arts do they want to hurt
people
thanks to Chazz Rhone the next
generation of shark conservationists is
just getting started to some ancient
civilizations great whites were treated
as gods to modern moviegoers they are
monsters but their true role in our
ecosystem like somewhere in between and
the very health of our planet's oceans
depends on them all right we gotta get
back in the boat please jump out of the
water but he's raising a good point
about the importance arcs are to our
environment where most people are afraid
of them but the people that work with
them and love them say it's a totally
different world they're so powerful and
so beautiful yeah yeah I would
I'm so envious and they're known as the
oceans top predator but you know what
the real top predator is us